el agente home está transfiriendo
archivos desde la base de datos hasta
una memoria portátil esta es la fórmula
del tamaño de los archivos en la memoria
de la gente john s
medido en megabytes como una función del
tiempo de medido en segundos completa
las siguientes proposiciones con los
valores faltantes apropiados cuando la
transferencia comenzó la memoria tenía
espacio en blanco megabytes de archivos
en ella y bueno cuando la transferencia
comenzó eso significa en el tiempo de
igual a cero de igual a cero y es justo
cuando la transferencia comenzó entonces
si te es igual a cero s de 0 s de 0
cuánto va a ser bueno esto va a ser
igual a 5 x 0 estoy sustituyendo aquí
a 45 que por supuesto estos se van y me
va a quedar solamente 45 y nos dice que
ese está medido en megabytes por lo
tanto puedo decir que tenemos 45
megabytes 45 megabytes de archivos en su
memoria justo en el momento en el que
comenzó a la transferencia después dice
cada 10 segundos se transfieren espacio
blanco megabytes adicionales a la
memoria así que cada 10 segundos
cuántos megabytes vamos a transferir y
bueno una forma de pensar en esto de
hecho hay muchas formas en las que puedo
pensar este problema pero una de ellas
es decir que si sabemos que antes de
empezar a transferencia teníamos 45
megabytes en el tiempo te igual a cero
pues pensemos que pasara 10 segundos
después cuántos megabytes habrá en su
memoria así que podemos decir que es de
10 s de 10 esto va a ser exactamente
igual que 55 que multiplica a 10 más 45
más 45 lo cual es lo mismo que 50 más 45
así que en el tiempo de igual a cero
teníamos 45 megabytes de información y
10 segundos después tenemos 50 más 45
megabytes
así que 10 segundos después tenemos 50
megabytes adicionales y esto es justo lo
que esperamos porque si te incremente en
uno bueno pues esta función va a crecer
en cinco es justo lo que tenemos aquí y
si te incrementen 10 bueno esta función
incrementaría en 50 así que por cada 10
segundos
el agente tendrá 50 megabytes
adicionales en su memoria
y esto lo puedes comprobar si tú quieres
viendo qué pasa en otros 10 segundos es
decir ese de 20 segundos esto a que va a
ser igual bueno a 5 por 20 más 45 lo
cual es lo mismo que 5 por 20 100 100
más 45 así que observa que cuando pasan
10 segundos extras en el tiempo es decir
incrementamos el tiempo en 10 segundos
estamos incrementando la memoria usada
en megabytes o los megabytes que estamos
transfiriendo incrementan en 50
aumentamos en 50